nah
Canada Centre in Toronto Ontario
hello everyone and welcome to the main
event it's time to spa
go into Game one it's
be here the fans are amazing like you
guys have such great energy it feels I'm
so honored to be here I feel I feel a
little bit overwhelmed the wild dream it
feels like home regardless of where we
are in Canada ladies and gentlemen
counter logic gaming introducing their
opponents it's the group that never says
die it's three times I'll see a shabby
I mean vain us on again great spirits
refugees smoking so much damage told you
it's a randomization barely creeps away
then the killer lady Charis going up
still hit on earth the wild total gah he
walked the head eternally he gave the
trip what did it feel like playing for
this crowd I felt amazing play for the
home crowd I loved her on I love all my
pens I love Canada feels awesome being
home and playing its perennial power
introducing their opponents they're the
only team to qualify for every LCS final
in every World Championship t ass
support it's the rookie of the split by
frost
well I never would have thought I would
be at this point like three months ago
so it's definitely really nice and the
cod super amazing they're very
supportive 1600 damage print although
meteos another knocketh trades his life
with a devilish UGA technically all
guilty they've got three if it goes down
and a's for dsm double it turns around
the fight staying alive so much bass
you're gonna give them nothing to stand
in their way as TSM cement themselves as
the most dominant organization North
American League of Legends and win their
fourth North American Championship
well Chris I just want to point out so
funny that uh now that we want the LG
goes the world so it's like two years
ago the og relies on me to carry them in
the world it's ridicu this award belongs
to the 2016 North American LCS summer
split MVP ladies and gentlemen year 2016
New York shin I think I can say for all
of us Oh Canada we'll see you at the
regional qualifier yeah Canada looking
at the gauntlet coming up so we've got
some teams competing in that what are
your expectations for who you think
might come out of that and how strong
you think that that might look for them
uh well now that this is all over i can
say that i really hope immortals losses
because they really really wanted us to
lose and then wouldn't scream us because
they I think they didn't want to play
cloud nine in the gauntlet so I still
thought that was a pretty scary thing to
do which is just like intentionally
blockade of screaming so I really hope
they lose also think la 9 is pretty good
and they should be able to beat
immortals again
you